let's now consider the generalization of
the result that the torque on a single
particle about a point causes the
angular momentum of that particle about
that point to change to a collection of
particles so let's begin by indicating
some ice particle with momentum P I and
some J particle over here with momentum
P J and this is a big system of n
particles and we'd like to calculate the
angular momentum about some point s so
that angular momentum will consist of
the direct product of the vector from s
to the I start achill and the direct
particle product of the vector RS to the
j DH particle so the angular momentum
total will be the sum over all the
particles one to end of this sum RS j
cross P J now what we'd like to do is
again as before take the time derivative
of this angular momentum we have the sum
j goes from 1 to n we have two
derivatives here by the product rule
across PJ plus the sum J goes from 1 to
N of RS j cross F J where we use the
fact as we did before that the force on
the j particle is equal to the change in
momentum of the j DH particle now this
first piece again the derivative of the
vector from s to the j part is the
velocity so we have J equals 1 to n of
the the velocity of the j particle cross
m j pj and that's zero
as we know that a vector cross product
with itself is zero and this piece in
here now we have to be a little bit
careful
but our s J cross F J is the torque on
the jth particle so that is the torque
on the J the particle now remember that
we showed that internal the forces on
the J particle could be both due to
internal or external forces and as long
as the internal forces pointed between
two particles pointed along the line
connecting those particles the internal
torques cancel in pairs and this will
only be the external torque so we've
assumed that the internal torques
canceled in pair and that has to do with
an assumption about the direction of the
internal forces and so we can conclude
that this is just the total external
torque about the point s s total and
we'll drop that total and we'll conclude
that the torque for a system of
particles is just causes the angular
momentum of the system of particles to
change the calculation is exactly like
the single particle with a few
subtleties that have to do with internal
torques canceling in pairs